62 cadáveres han sido recuperados en las
costas de calabria en el sur de Italia
víctimas del naufragio este domingo de
una precaria embarcación en la que más
de 200 migrantes originarios de
Afganistán Siria Irán y Pakistán
llevaban cuatro días viajando desde
Turquía la jefa de gobierno Georgia
melón y en un comunicado denunció las
redes de traficantes de migrantes que
organizan estos peligrosos viajes son
presunto traficante fue detenido por las
autoridades italianas se trataría de un
ciudadano Turco la tragedia ha generado
en Italia una ola de indignación entre
las víctimas hay más de 30 mujeres un
recién nacido Y al menos 12 menores de
edad que murieron tratando de cruzar la
ruta migratoria más peligrosa del mundo
en los últimos diez años casi 25,000
migrantes y refugiados han muerto
tratando de atravesar el mar
Mediterráneo